the weight for no man's sky has been a
long one but lucky for us the ambitious
sci fi game is only a few months away
and you could be able to preorder it
starting this week so far we haven't
really heard anything about pre orders
or priced until now according to a
listing on the playstation blog today
pre-orders could open on March third but
this information has since been removed
from the page luckily game zone was able
to capture an image of this post before
it was taken down now this could have
easily been a mistake as all mention of
no man's sky on the page has since been
removed the post also revealed that no
man's sky will be a sixty-dollar game
before this hello games had not
mentioned a price point for the game in
terms of an official release date hello
games said at paris games week last
summer that no man's sky will launch in
june 2016 it will come to playstation 4
and pc on the same day previously the
game was expected to launch first on ps4
as a timed exclusive if no man's sky
pre-orders do indeed open on March third
we'll be sure to let you know